hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in the final chapter number 13 of his
treatise on truth anselm is going to
lead us through back and forth dialogue
and argumentation to the point where we
are supposed to see
that there is a unity of truth itself or
of rectitude
veritas rectitudo are the terms that
he's using there and this will
ultimately be truth itself capital t
that is
god there is some prefiguration of this
going on in two earlier
chapters for example chapter 10 he's
going to talk about the highest or
supreme truth
which is god as being the cause of all
other rectitudes all other rightnesses
which is what truth consists in for
these different
modalities of signification and willing
and truth even in the existence or the
being of things right
and then in chapter 11 we're going to
get a definition of truth rectitude
perceivable by the mind alone which
encompasses all of these different kinds
of truth including
the supreme truth as well
and now notice this is very important
that he's not saying rectitude of
willing of action of speech of you know
thinking of
the very being of things he's just
talking about rightness or rectitude per
se
and any kind of rightness that's
perceivable by the mind that falls under
these categories is going to be truth
now
this raises
a really important
question for him and his student at the
beginning
of chapter 13.
is truth
one
or is it
plural
and you know even with having a supreme
truth a truth that's at like the top of
the pyramid or what however you want to
represent it
it is conceivable that there could be
a number of different
modalities of truth maybe the supreme
truth is just like the highest truth or
the best truth or truth you know
deserving a capital t but these other
kinds of truths are not the same thing
as
the supreme truth and they have their
own
being their own whatever we want to call
it
their own
disconnected legitimacy or separated
existence
despite whether they're connected with
the highest truth or not and so here's
the key question
is there one truth
one single truth in all things and
things there is race which is this very
broad category
that we say truth is in so is there one
single truth that exists in
thoughts whether it be cognition or
judgment in
signification whether it be you know
the the first or the second kind of
signification that anselm discusses
in the will
in action whether in
rational not necessary action or
irrational necessary action in the very
being or existence of things
there's a lot of stuff already right is
there one truth in all these things that
we have said
truth is in throughout this entire
treatise
or
here's another possibility
are there
as many truths as many kinds of truth
as there are things called true
this second statement by the way could
be taken in two different ways
maybe we say that
there are as many truths as there are
singular things which could be like
states of affairs
or
you know single sentences or pick
whatever you want
single volitions called true so like
maybe there are a myriad of truths
just in my own history
of willing and action and talking
expression thinking right maybe there's
like an infinity of truths just in the
lifetime of a single person or maybe
what anselm is suggesting here is that
there's uh different modalities of truth
so you've got a kind of truth over here
that is the truth in
signification there is a kind of truth
over here that is the truth in action
now of course they're connected together
because every action is significative
and every signification is an action put
that aside maybe there's really
two or three or four or five or how many
kinds of truth we have
major types of
things
right and anselm draws out some some you
know interesting conclusions
that would follow if we accept the
second alternative he says
if there must be as many different
rectitudes rightnesses as there are
things their existence or rather their
their being right their essay
in latin
would depend upon or would be derived
from those things secundum
race right so
if there's truth in signification and
truth in the will
then the rectitude of truth in
signification would be derived from
sequendum
signification and the
rectitude the rightness the truth of
willing would be derived
from the will okay so that
signifies a kind of
ontological dependency or a causality if
you like right
and that would be a problem in part
because after all
we've seen earlier
that all truths are ultimately going to
be causally connected with the supreme
truth
but there'd be another problem there as
well
rectitudes themselves would be
varied
right
and he uses uh
you know this this terminology there in
latin that's very cognate with this
right um
literally they would be the kinds of
things that differ from each other just
as those things those kinds of things
willing signification action
being
vary from each other
right in latin so
that would be a problem too because then
we'd have a hard time saying
how are these different truths actually
connected with each other we would have
like truth and signification over here
and that's really got nothing in common
with truth in willing over here
and you know maybe that's the case
anselm thinks that it's not
and
he's going to approach this in kind of
an interesting way
so the student is going to bring up a
mistaken analogy
and he's going to say that
maybe
signification and rectitude are
connected together
like
body
and color now what would this mean so
if you've got a body
it has to have color because that's the
nature of bodies even if you call it
transparent okay well it's it's the
colors of the thing that you're seeing
through it right we can't really get out
of this
but that doesn't tell you that there has
to be any body and color is dependent
upon body right so maybe let's take
signification maybe
rectitude or rightness or truth of
signification
is dependent upon right as we saw here
the signification if you don't have
signification no truth right so if i'm
not saying anything i'm not saying
anything true i'm also not lying almost
perhaps i'm you know gesturing through
my not saying something
and the student thinks that this is not
a bad analogy at the start he says
rectitude exists only in signification
and changes when signification does just
as color has existence and non-existence
in body if the body exists its color
necessarily is when the body is
destroyed the color cannot remain
and anselm says no this is not a good
analogy why not
and he goes on to say we can learn
something from this
if no one wishes to signify what a sign
ought to mean will the sign have any
signification and the student says no no
that it won't that's the point here and
then anselm says
how then can it be correct in order to
signify what it ought to
and the student says rectitude won't be
on this account be any less nor need
this be any less and
anselm goes on and says when it does not
mean it does not lose the rectitude by
which it exists and which requires it to
signify what it ought to and then he
goes on and says do you think that when
what ought to be signified is signified
which means it's it's true right the
signification is correct on account of
and according to this rectitude and the
student says well yeah right and then
anselm says
well that rectitude is there
whether or not the sign or set of signs
exists or not the rectitude is always
going to be there
and we measure
the signification
by
the rectitude that remains
when the sign
and the signification
ends even going forward from that
he says
do you not see that there is no
rectitude and signification which comes
into existence when what is said to be
or what is said not to be
what is not is not said not to be but
that signification then comes to be
according to a rectitude which always is
always exists
and when it means what it should or
nothing at all then it falls away from a
never failing rectitude and the student
says something very interesting here i
see that i'm unable not to see this the
very interesting locution there right
i realized that i was talking nonsense
before or i was talking something that
was false and now i see the truth of
what truth is in signification the truth
is not of signification the
signification is rather of truth right
and anselm goes on and says you know the
same thing can be said for the other
rectitudes right
not only is this this analogy of body to
color
and uh
signification to rectitude that doesn't
work because the rectitude is always
there the truth is always there and the
signification is measured according to
that
or embodies that
this also holds he says for will and its
rectitude and of the other things that
ought to have rectitude and the student
goes on and says
i see that by this argument is also
proved completely that
however it be with these rectitude
remains immutable and so we've got a
really interesting thing accomplished
here right so
we've dealt with what we could call the
ontological priority you know here
of is it is it the thing that is
supposed to be true that makes the truth
be the truth or is it the other way
around
and we've also got that there's a
connection between these different
modalities of truth now they're going to
go even further though
and say that this leads us to the point
of saying there is not actually a
plurality
of truths or rectitudes there is just
one
ultimate
truth
and that's a much stronger claim
isn't it so he goes on and he says
i said earlier if there are as many
rectitudes as there are things in which
they are considered it's necessary they
exist they have being and vary as the
things themselves do this is the student
saying but this has been shown not to be
the case so there are not many
rectitudes just because rectitude is
found in many things
rectitude is found in many things
but
there's only actually one
ultimate rectitude and anselm says do
you have any argument other than the
plurality of things why they seem to to
be many and the student says well no and
so anselm says therefore there is one
and the same rectitude of all now that
leaves open the idea that maybe the
student doesn't actually
spend enough time thinking about other
objections that could be made but we're
going to put that aside because we're
interested in what's going on here so
anselm is going to say
that there is only one rectitude
and there's only one truth in all of
these things and then the student says
all right but this is confusing to me
because we do talk about the truth of
this thing and the truth of this thing
so
if they're the same truth why do we
index it to different
things and then anselm says we need to
like actually think about our language
here
he says it's improperly said to be of
this or that thing
because truth doesn't have its existence
or its being
and here is going to say three things it
doesn't have its its existence or being
in
in in latin
from
acts
or through
pair
those things
those things don't make the truth the
truth makes those things true
so he says
when those things are said to be
according to truth which always now this
is very interesting which always excels
them praisto s meaning it's always more
than what those things themselves
are
then uh truth is said to be of this or
that thing that is the truth of will or
the truth of action
and then he draws a really interesting
analogy here that he's going to close
the entire treaties with
everything true is ultimately in truth
and there's an analogy here to
time
itself and i leave it to you to think
about whether this is a good analogy or
not whether there's problems with it he
says
we speak of the time of this or that
thing although there is one in the same
time of everything that is together at
the same time
if this or that thing did not exist
there's still the same time
we don't say the time of this or that
thing because time is in those things
but because they are in
time
similarly he says we we can say that
the highest truth
subsists in itself and belongs to no
thing but when something is in accord
with it
then we speak of its truth and rectitude
so in a certain way everything is in
the truth of the highest
the supreme
truth right
so it's kind of a a weak analogy here to
time it's not he's not saying it's
exactly the same way
but what this shows us is that
for anselm there is a unity of truth it
doesn't prevent us from talking about
the truths of different things whether
these be individual things or whether
they be kinds of things like truth in
the will truth in action truth in
signification
but in a certain sense
truth
is
as the supreme being and everything else
is going to be
measured
structured made true in accordance with
that truth
you